what's going on guys we are
with we are in on base with mookie bets
this is my first show so I just messed
that up first show we got to Christian
Yelich here we're live in the BR app
make sure you hit us up in the comments
with all the questions comments whatever
it is
um so
further without further ado
we're going to get the Christian Yelich
what's going on Yeti what's up man
thanks for having me first of all you
ain't had to do me like that yesterday
yeah that's my bad I'm sure you've
gotten me before in the last 10 years
I was grinding but I had me a nice
little soft single uh you're never
you're never grinding whatever man all
right so
yelly uh I thought we had we have we
have a nice connection
um 2018 we're both MVPs
um I want to run off your stats real
quick so obviously 2018 NL MVP your
two-time All-Star
is that three time now two two-time
All-Star three-time Silver Slugger and a
Gold Glove winner
that's uh
that's some dope stuff bro so now it's
no mookie best it doesn't have to be
mookie bro close we got those we got a
little something yeah a little something
you know this is Christian Yelich bro so
um tell me tell me about 2018 what do
you what do you uh remember the most
um you know it was my first year here in
Milwaukee so um
you kind of how it is when you're kind
of learning a new place new team
um you know all I'd known was Miami and
the Marlins
um at first and then come here kind of
just getting your feet wet and then it
turned into a special season kind of
just after the All-Star break where um
you know things started clicking we had
a good team we actually ended up losing
the Dodgers before we were going to play
you guys
um in the world series that year and
then that was a dope series too it was
it kind of kind of went either way that
one that one still hurts old but you
lost your boy Bentley we lost it we lost
the belly belly it was the one that beat
us in the in game seven pretty much he
hit that he hit the two run Homer and
then that was kind of a wrap for us but
uh it was a cool it was a cool season
man that's kind of how we got to know
each other a little bit after that um
and then playing against each other
obviously so what what like in that
season like what clicked you know what
I'm saying like it kind of can you say
what clicked because I can tell like for
me I found a mechanic right yeah I found
a mechanic that I could just repeat over
that's what I was gonna say is a
you know you're always tinkering in
baseball right like you're always trying
to you're always trying to get better
um
you know nothing ever stays the same
like you have to find and then when you
have those really special years like
like you said it's one little thing that
you can repeat over and over again like
it's a simple cue or a simple
movement that you can just you can do
all the time which puts you in a good
position doesn't matter who's pitching
right and you're just like I have
control of everything like you're just
like I'm on time for everything
and this is how it goes and so that's
kind of what happened was it was more of
a timing thing than anything it was like
I changed the timing a little bit to be
just like a little earlier so you just
see everything a lot better and then
really just like where you're making
contact gets better and then you start
driving the ball you know what sucks
like trying to find that again when it
comes when it goes It goes when you're
in the when you're in the middle of it
you're like oh this is never going to
change I'm going to be I'm gonna be
doing this forever
and then when it goes man it's uh it's
tough to get back it's one of those
things where you know it's one of the
most frustrating sports for for a reason
just because
you know it's just you can be there
forever and then one day you just show
up and then it's just it's gone randomly
and how does that happen we spend all
day and night I'm sure you hit in the
mirror right oh yeah take BP in the
mirror oh yeah everybody's like all of
us why are they admitted or not exactly
everybody hits in the mirror everybody
and you try and repeat this move and it
just
doesn't come back you know but it's you
know it is what it is but you're just
constantly adjust like you have to I
think each year you have like a new
swing whether it's major or minor like
each Year's its own year so like you're
the way your body moves everything kind
of changes
um whether as you get older you deal
with injury stuff like you're always
kind of trying to make adjustments and
get better and I think the guys that can
do it for a really long time at a high
level they're they're able to to make
changes and adapt to the game getting
older their bodies
um and like that's kind of what you do
like you're like you know what in 18
19 whatever years right yeah I'm just
not that guy anymore so I just got to be
the guy I am right now yeah you just
kind of try and work with what you got
and like trust me I've been I've banged
my head against the wall for years
trying to trying to like repeat that and
get that back and then at some point you
gotta like all right it's got to make an
adjustment and kind of started doing
that the last month or so yeah they're
just like all right whatever that was
it's just like it's not working like
that right now maybe it comes back at
some point but
you got to do what gives you a chance to
succeed because I mean if you think
about it before even when the mechanic
clicked
it just kind of clicked right you know
what I'm saying it just happened so you
know and you weren't necessarily looking
for it it just kind of happened we're
looking for something that just kind of
happens well there's no there's no one
way to do it I don't think like you you
think that's the only way because like
that's when you had your most success
you're like I want to chase that
but if you watch guys around like
everybody hits different so there's not
really one way to do it and really all
it is is just putting your body in a
position consistently to like have
success like to to be on time to be in a
good position to like launch from like
that's all you really need to do how you
get there
doesn't really matter it changes right
so like it can change and like
once you do that you're like all right I
just got to figure out how to get there
whether it's the way I did it in 18 or
the way I'm going to try and do it now
and like it's just a game of constant
adjustments and the guys that kind of
Jessica those are the guys that those
are the guys are still around for a long
time yeah you're right all right bro so
um there's a little game it's called Uh
on base and off base especially like
true or false yeah
um you you're the in or out all right so
the first thing
getting Chipotle
142 days in a row
office I mean everybody so I've seen
that a bunch and trust me like you
played the minor leagues
when you're in the minor leagues you're
going to Chipotle yeah like it's just
it's just what it is you're in a bunch
of small towns there's not a ton of
options so if you're like all right like
let's go
I don't know if me and JT went we didn't
definitely didn't go 142 days in a row
that's psychotic behavior
that's a little crazy we did go a lot we
did go a lot because I think it was in
um
it was in Greensboro
and then somebody said somewhere along
the line like in the last few years that
like we just went every day and then it
just kind of ran with it they started
putting it on scoreboards and stadiums
and then it kind of just took off but so
are you ever just gonna like roll with
it with them
something I just told them it just
relative I guess that's cool I got one
of those uh I got one of those Chipotle
cards out of it so you still got one I
did it's it was like the they do it for
like a year so I had it for like a
couple years completely off Chipotle now
because you did that no no I'm not I'm
not off it I wouldn't say I definitely
don't go as much as I used to in the in
the minor leaks but it's in the it's in
the rotation every now and then all
right what about uh taking your shoes
off on the plane off face or on base uh
try off base I think on on our on our I
want to be comfortable on our flights
yeah you can I feel like yeah but if
you're going on like a normal commercial
flight yeah no no but we do during the
season yeah yeah I mean definitely I
wear socks yeah you can do whatever you
want them regular commercial flights and
then I just will dispose of the socks
because you know airplanes are nasty but
if I walked to the airport with socks no
I don't do just the plane though I won't
get comfortable I don't know I'm on base
that's fair that's fair I get it I gotta
try that out then I can't say I'm in men
are out on the next I have never tried
it well I mean we're just going to roll
it off base because uh all right you
know but but on and uh regular price so
what about Darkness retreats
I've never done a Darkness Retreat I
have to ask Aaron about that one yeah
yeah so he's bigger
you ever done one now I figured you and
Aaron y'all were cool y'all here in
Milwaukee together I feel like four days
four days in the darks uh or three days
however long it is it's a little it's a
little do you know what it's supposed to
be for like that like what is it
supposed to really know I feel like
you're supposed to like see things maybe
or you're kind of just spend time with
like it's high sensory deprivation when
you see things in the dark maybe I kind
of heard that if you spend like a lot of
time in the dark
you start to like have like
hallucinations and stuff and like see
some stuff and learn about your life I
don't know I've never I've never done it
and I don't really plan on doing it
right now but okay so we're not straight
you're off on on Darkness or trees what
about
um
comparisons to to Pete Davidson in or
out on that I've gotten that a lot yep
uh I think it started in 2014 or 15. I
did the it was on intentional talk yeah
and someone they asked like if you ever
get any comparisons and that was like
before Pete kind of took off he was
still he was on SNL still but he was
kind of just starting out
um
and they set it on there and then it
kind of got back to him and he came out
the city field when we played the Mets
there dressed up
um as me and kind of took BP which they
didn't tell anybody that he was coming
so like the the strength coach was
running stretch was like who's this guy
like no they didn't know
because the Marlins didn't tell anybody
that he was showing up they just like
rolled him out there and they thought it
was like a plan or something so what's
the what's the weird have you ever had
like a weird place that you were like oh
that's Pete Davidson no one's ever come
up to me and thought I was like actually
Pete but
every night we play Somebody's screaming
so that Pete Davidson at me especially
on the road do you see it or no are you
like I don't know he I've I've met him a
few times and he he knows about like
because he gets it a little bit or he
used to get a little bit too
um we kind of both agree that we don't
really look too much like each other so
you're off base on Pete Davidson
probably yeah okay all right all right
what about uh the Home Run celebrations
with props
yeah I mean
I guess you kind of have to be on base
without it yeah
I'm like all right it's kind of
it it kind of just how the game's going
yeah like I I could I could take it a
little bit you got to play in WBC so
right so what'd you think of that by the
way it was amazing it's amazing right
that was the best baseball experience
I've ever it's incredible and people get
mad when you say that but it's just a
different
it's a different experience then it's a
different anything else because I went
into it being like okay like I'm getting
out of spring training this would be
cool to play for Team USA
like obviously you want to win and it's
pride and then when you show up and that
game starts like you have like this
whole another like competitive feeling
we're not losing we can't lose like
completely different than that
atmosphere is incredible
um so it's really hard to describe to
people until you've like actually been a
part of it yeah and it's like this is
amazing like you want to do it as many
times as you can because it's a is
better than spring training it's way
better than it's just like you got to
play with like in All-Star games you're
there for like two days with the guys
it's so busy and you don't really have a
time to like it's you're not really on
the same team like for that you're on
the same team for like two weeks and you
get to play with these guys and talk to
them and that was the thing I think that
was the best thing was getting to talk
to them and
um begin to learn their routines what
makes them them go getting to see them
be competitive as well you know yeah
that was the coolest part was just
seeing guys like do their thing and
obviously some of the best players in
the game and then you come together yeah
I think that was the what I really
enjoyed the most is that
it was I don't even know how many guys
are on the team but yeah just we're not
all random we kind of know each other
but you get in you get in that and you
just come together like you don't I
don't know these people right but we're
all on the same team we're rooting for
the yeah room for each other you got you
get the plane rides bus rides you go to
dinners like you got practices too yeah
so you become a team and especially over
that amount of time and then short
you're in that atmosphere where it's
like you're with the boys and a lot of
the times like you're the you're not the
team that everybody's rooting for
depending on like what city or Stadium
or team you're paying for so it's a cool
atmosphere when it's like you and the
boys against like 45 000 yeah yeah yeah
that was fun it's sick all right so what
about the pitch clock
I like it I really do I kind of wish it
was I kind of wish it was 20 seconds the
whole time I think I think that would
make it a little bit easier I mean
I don't know how you feel about it but I
feel like the the 15 seconds with nobody
on base like
if you look down at all
it's like a 10 and you're like oh God
there's no time you know I I think it's
dope I think it really has helped like
like last night I mean you guys scored
nine mm-hmm and um
usually when that happens in so long
that's a long game keeps it moving yeah
but the game was still under three hours
yeah I mean it's great you get home eat
dinner right I think it shows how much
dead time like they're used like nobody
likes that four hour nine inning game
those would just those would just drag
you know and it makes the season so much
longer too where you're just like you're
out there like you said if you're
getting blown out or you're blowing
somebody out like the game kind of just
crawls and then
you know I kind of got a guy out there
walking around taking a minute between
pitches and it's like come on man like
let's move let's move this thing along
but it's been good I think it it was a
little bit of an adjustment period
um obviously you're gonna have the every
now and then you know you're gonna get
you're gonna be banged with the strike
or something something's gonna happen
but I think for the most part it's good
I've I've liked it so far so
staying on the pitch clock situation
what do you think about because a couple
guys got banged when they had their
going home party like so when I go back
to Boston
I'm just gonna have to take a strike you
know I'm saying or or you know I think
they can submit they can now I think
they said I'm submitting it for them
so I I I I think that that's crazy how
you gonna bang somebody you know what
I'm saying I just feel like there should
be some feel there like it's not that
hard to like
no like you're not trying to waste time
yeah you're not you're not there being
like Oh I don't care like I'm just gonna
I'm just gonna take five minutes before
I get in the box like obviously you've
won World Series MVPs for you know that
City and team like obviously they're
going to show you love just like when
belly came back and played you guys and
yep
um he got banged yeah we were like oh my
gosh one of that none of us want to
check you know come on like
the umpires know what's going on like
they're not trying to and I don't know
if they just don't have a choice or what
the deal is but uh and that kid that
made his debut after 13 years in the
minor leagues yeah the animation like
hey bud oh one yeah that was crazy go
get him that was crazy yeah so all right
so
[Music]
um the main point of the show is I want
to I want to know like kind of how you
got learn about you but also how you got
to
Christian Yelich you know what I'm
saying and so kind of talk about your
life a little bit so grew up in Southern
California yeah Thousand Oaks I think I
live like 15 minutes from there by the
way yeah it's close great area great
area so
you grew up going to Dodger games yeah
all the time
so you were a Dodger fan yeah I remember
I sat in the uh every time we play there
I kind of know like where in the stadium
like I used to sit oh I think my first
ever Dodger game up in the blue seats I
think it was like the third Baseline
maybe like the third or fourth row up in
the in the the top section
I don't remember who they're playing I
want to see you like the reds or the
Phillies or somebody like that but then
um
yeah that was that was where I used to
sit and then yeah everything tickets up
there no no no season tickets but uh I
had buddies and stuff there's like I
think I had a friend or two that maybe
their family had season tickets or they
would go all the time and then you get
to sit in like that lower bowl okay I
thought that was the coolest thing ever
because you're like on the first level
and you got to watch you know a major
league game like that close when you're
a kid or like changing in the parking
lot of daughter Stadium like coming from
a baseball game changing out of like
your baseball uniform put on like
regular clothes probably just smelling
terrible yeah when you're like 12 years
old
yeah
that was pretty that's pretty cool so
give me give me like what about uh you
got like three
favorite baseball moments that you
remember
from Dodger Stadium from the doctor
Stadium
um
it's okay I think just like
just like my favorite thing about like
going to games as a kid was just like
get in the parking lot and like walking
up to the stadium okay like you know
like you're going to the game like
you're not in there yet but you see the
stadium and like you know now we kind of
get so used to it because like that's
just like your that's your office you go
there every day so it's like
it kind of wears off a little bit we're
just like yeah this is cool like
obviously it's awesome playing in the
big leagues but when you're a kid like
you see like the big stadium and then
like you finally get in and you can you
see the field you're like damn like this
is cool and like I vividly remember
sitting there with like my buddies and
stuff being like man that'd be so cool
to be out there one day yeah
um you know like I wonder all the stuff
that these guys get like you know when
you're a kid like you care about the
gear right yeah batting gloves and like
the cleats and all that stuff that's
like I still I still remember that and
like all that and I remember first time
playing at Dodger Stadium was was
something it was super cool I remember
being pretty nervous actually for it and
you know you probably had a lot of fam
there a ton of people the first time and
then year after year after year kind of
the world trickles down and like you
still have like your your core group of
buddies and family and stuff that goes
when you're out there but
um I remember having a ton of people and
I just remember before that game I was
like man if there's any game like not to
suck like just please be this
four days from now you can do terrible
yeah but tonight like please do good but
you're you're a Jeter fan growing up as
well yeah I like Jeter I mean that was
just kind of when I was learning
baseball
um like the Yankees were always on TV
like the late 90s they were always
winning they're always in the playoffs
in the World Series so as a kid like you
don't know a ton yet you just kind of
watch sports on TV and so
watching the playoffs seeing Jeter
obviously
um the role he played on those teams and
be on the Yankees he kind of became
familiar with him and so
um I really like watching him play I
think the guys on the Dodger at the time
was like they were like Sean green and
Eric gagne and Eric carros like those
those guys were playing when I was going
to the games back back then but um that
was cool so so so
[Music]
so would it have me meant a lot if you
could could have put on like would you
have been like man I wonder or you
didn't care you just wanted to just be
in the league
um yeah I mean I think that'd be that'd
be pretty cool I mean it's just one of
those things where you just don't know
how your your career is going to play
out like you don't necessarily have
control
but as a kid like growing up you're like
yeah this would be this would be really
cool just because that's where you
that's where you learned
baseball yeah I was like
um listening to Vin Scully and just like
going to these games and like
I grew up yeah 30 40 minutes from the
stadium so we'd go to Angel games did
you get to play with Jeter as well like
uh did you play against them in spring
training one time was that cool super
cool it wasn't it was in uh we played in
Panama for a uh Mariano Rivera like just
retired the year before so it was like
Marlins Yankees and Panama for like a
tribute series to Tomo and uh
I think I might have been a rookie or
had like a couple months in the league
at that time and CeCe was pitching I was
leading off and Jeter was playing
shortstop and um
I kind of remember like get in the Box
looking out he's doing like his whole
like pre-pre-game pre-pitch routine
I remember like oh like just the big
leagues it's kind of like time like time
I knew I need a second and then uh get
back in and do it but I remember that
being pretty cool
um
yeah I got to me I got to meet him and
uh
I don't really get nervous when I meet
people nah
um but maybe it's because I was I was 21
and my debuted in Yankee Stadium and
um
the day that the day before I got to
meet him and I was shaking they're
shaking when I got I was nervous too
actually yeah but like you had just this
present yeah well it's just different
like you know like you said you get to
meet a lot of cool people
um especially doing what we do like you
get you just meet a lot of people but
there's a few there's a few people where
you're like oh yeah like and he's he's
one of them yeah he was definitely he
was definitely one of them so you uh
planned I'm assuming you signed you
signed a letter of intent to go to Miami
um the Marlins drafted you yeah
um and so you decided to sign how was
that I know you signed right before the
deadline so
I didn't think I was gonna like when I
when I committed to college at the time
like I actually thought I was going to
go to college like I wasn't one I wasn't
like a super hyped draft guy like some
of these guys that are in high school
now are called like they know that
they're gonna be drafted in like the
first round and there's no chance
they're going to school I wasn't really
that good like I never made a Team USA I
never made any like the All-American
games were the exact same right like I
never made any of that stuff tried to
got cut from all of it
but uh it was like I wasn't a great
showcase player as a kid
I could hit like our arm was not good
like I could run a little bit but I was
never like the fastest 60 guys never
hitting the farthest homers in BP like
but when the game started I could always
play
um but it doesn't necessarily like show
up in the in the Showcase format because
like you don't have any tools that like
jump off the page you know so at the
time like I thought I was going to
college when I committed and there was a
there was like a Showcase of like the
Urban Youth Academy out in La
um with like a bunch of kids and
everybody from like all over like the
West Coast United States
and like the kind of the Stars just like
a line that day like had a really good
showcase like played really good in the
game had like a really good batting
practice ran a good 60 and then like
the game started and got a bunch of hits
and then after that
kind of started being in the the draft
conversation but at the time of like
making the college commitment I thought
for sure I was going to school you know
and then even when the draft happened
like I didn't know where I was going to
be picked like I didn't even know the
Marlins were going to pick me like they
never talked to me or anything before
the draft and then I remember kind of
watching it on TV uh I wasn't even
looking at the TV at the time because
the Marlins were picking and I was like
I haven't talked to these guys ever like
they're not definitely not picking me
and then I heard my name on the TV oh
wow okay I guess I'm drafted by the
Marlins so yeah that's cool yeah I I did
that same stuff you know right right
before the deadline I was going to
school I mean I'm packing my clothes up
yeah
um you know and then you hear your name
and then your adrenaline starts rushing
into everything and I didn't know what I
wanted to do like
like I definitely wanted to play pro
ball yeah but you're 18 years old like I
was in high school
two months earlier you know what I mean
and so I kind of went all the way down
to the deadline because like I didn't
really know I didn't really know what
they're gonna offer me at the time
and
once I signed I was like I think I'll
know how this is going to go pretty
early on yep like you'll you kind of
know inside of you like if you can hack
it or not yeah
and I was like well I guess if this
doesn't work out like I'll just I'll
just go to school you know afterwards
like I'll know after a few years how
it's going to go but I was like this is
really what I want to do
um
I was like all right like
let's do it and see what happens so you
got drafted you ended up you know
signing and then you go into minor
league ball and this is when people
forget about the draft the guys that
were drafted a couple years ago right
because you go into this
you know
I mean
you know what I'm saying the jungle yeah
the jungle there you go it's the jungle
and and and you so you're grinding there
right indeed did you grind there really
so because I mean you got you drafted
drafted in in 10 and you debuted in 13.
yeah and so I know for me like I was
drafted in 11 and debuted in 14.
there was real I had realistically two
months that I I did not play well
outside of that I banged yeah the whole
time and so you had to have done the
same thing for me it was every every
level like the first month month and a
half I would kind of struggle a little
bit
um
and then after that you would kind of
get used to the level and start playing
good um
but it's really like the you have to
learn how to struggle I think like a big
part of baseball is like learning how to
fail because up until then you haven't
really failed a ton because you're
drafted like you're doing well you kind
of dominated high school or wherever
you're at like you're always kind of the
better athlete and just able to succeed
and then like you said you're kind of
just throwing into this mix and it
doesn't really matter if you're a first
round you don't know who you don't know
anybody yeah and you're just like here
we go
um I guess we're doing this thing and
kind of learn how to play I think
circumstances kind of helped a little
bit like you know
what team you're on yeah I don't know if
I would have I don't know if I would
have been in the big leagues in 2013 if
I was
anywhere but in Miami you know it was
kind of just an opportunity as a young
player to to play in the big leagues get
your feet wet the team wasn't great at
the time so they're kind of seeing
um what their young players could do and
you know obviously if you're in the
system of a perennial playoff team or a
team that has World Series aspirations
it's a little bit different like when
you come up you're expected to to
produce and you've got to contribute to
you know that goal the team of making
the playoffs and like when I came up my
first year we lost 100 games yeah so
it was a little bit different and kind
of fortunate in the fact that you kind
of got to learn on the job a little bit
but you got to fail in the big league
see what it was like without those like
crazy expectations right away and then
so much of like so much of this is like
getting an opportunity and then when you
get an opportunity taking advantage of
it you can't miss it because you don't
get a ton of them in the game like once
you once you come up like you kind of
have to play well otherwise you kind of
get that label of the the up and down
guy or like oh this guy's good in the
minor leagues but can't really do it in
the big leagues and that might not
necessarily be true like it's kind of
just timing like if you feel good at the
plate You're Gonna Play well and if
you're gonna grinding when you get
called up like it's gonna be a grind
yeah it's gonna be a grind yeah and
I think in today's game I don't know
about you but
a lot of these guys just get like when
they're in the minor leagues like
they're to the next face of the
franchise they're the Savior they're
going to be the next like watch the
draft in in two months like there's so
many
this guy's the next this guy's going to
be a perennial 30 30 guy in in the big
leagues I think that's what it is I
think to your point is I don't think
that part has changed right like the the
we those these guys are banging just
like we banged right but I think the the
expectations that people put on them has
changed yeah and you just gotta let guys
play and yeah big leagues like they're
going to be really good talented players
but it's so hard to come up
to the major leagues and play a while
right away there's only a handful of
guys that don't really like
struggle like everybody kind of comes up
and does well for like a week or two and
then then you struggle figures you out
and then you struggle and you just got
to adjust and it's just part of being a
young player in the big leagues like you
just have to learn
um learn on the job and you gotta take
the ups and downs and you so you got to
learn from some good guys from Stanton
yeah Stanton Ozuna Ozuna was a good hey
that guy can hit he can flat out yeah
what was it like playing an outfit with
them
I mean I I play with them all the way up
through the minor leagues and I remember
him being really really talented like he
could do he could do everything he had a
lot of power he had a great arm he could
run
I was like damn and then JT too like
yeah you play with a lot of guys in the
minor leagues were just like we didn't
know it at the time but we had like
eight or nine guys ended up playing and
they're still playing did you all play
together yeah Andy barquette was yeah
manager yeah yeah he was the man he was
my hitting coach yeah he used to tell me
about yali and Jay oh yeah my original
on the team Fernandez Mark Canna like we
had a pretty good looking back on it we
got a really talented minor league all
come through the miners I mean Marlin
yeah all at the same time too wow like
everybody everybody was down there um
and we just we didn't know any better at
the time but we thought everybody was
pretty talented and watching those guys
do their thing and then being a young
player coming up with those guys in the
big leagues is Ichiro and then Don who's
the manager yeah
um you know Stanton Juan Pierre like all
these being around a lot of
awesome veteran players kind of showing
you the way in the big leaf early on I
mean Jeff Mathis had a big impact on on
my career for sure
um oh yeah a lot you were you were
around dudes yeah just kind of you you
never really wanted to disappoint him
either like yeah they would never get
mad at you they'd just like come on man
yeah you'd feel so bad you're like but
it was probably that probably was good
that was probably kind of good for you
yeah you know because it kind of like
pushed you yeah where you just like
didn't want to do anything to where like
they would be disappointed like you
always wanted the veteran players to
like you I felt like you're just like
all right I got it I gotta lock it in
like yeah I can't do that especially
playing but like off the field is the
part that that you really don't want to
disappoint them like you know don't
forget the beer forget the beer I forgot
it in Kansas City one time and that's
such a far that's such a far walk back
to the clubhouse it's like a quarter
mile back to the clubhouse you're
sprinting because like we're gonna leave
you yeah
I'll never forget that
um all right so
I want to ask this bro you have Berry
bonds as a hitting coach yeah and I had
Ken Griffey Jr as a hitting coach and
I'm gonna tell you my experience and I
want to hear about yours yeah so Griff
was our hitting coach for Team USA
and
obviously we know Griff is King River
Junior yeah
and I think sometimes like when it when
he would help us with hitting because he
has all the knowledge in the world right
I think sometimes I couldn't understand
it and if he was saying it correctly
yeah but I just I because he was Ken
Griffey Jr and he could do it yeah I
think he may have thought that I could
do it right and I can't do you know what
I'm saying some of the things but he was
amazing and all the knowledge that I
learned about just purely like
taking pictures or how to take pictures
or or just how to navigate at bats yeah
like that is stuff that he taught me
that
I mean it's Irreplaceable you know and
so I want to hear about Barry Bonds
because a lot of it's not mechanical a
lot of it is is just mental thought
based yeah
I mean Barry was so so talented like
everything he did like we were talking
about earlier about just like simple
repeatable he was like he had one of the
most simple repeatable strings of all
time and that's why he was able to do
what he did and
like him talking about hitting and
watching him hit it looked so easy like
he was watching yeah he would like
demonstrate like the drill or what he
was talking about in the cage and you'd
just be watching like man like this
looks so easy yeah and then you'd go in
there and try and do it and you just
smother it I can't do that you know
you're just like he talked about his Top
Hand a lot and like catching the ball
like you just like if I can catch it
yeah that's his drill right right if you
can put a glove on and if you can catch
it and he's like if I can go from here
to here before you throw a ball from 60
feet to the plate like I got you he's
like you can it doesn't matter how hard
you throw like I'm still gonna get you
and I remember I remember asking him
what he thought about the shift I was
like Barry what do you think about the
shift because that's kind of when the
shift was just starting out again like
he used to get shifted all the time for
the most of us like we weren't really
getting shifted a whole lot back then I
was like what do you think about the
shift okay he was like man the only
thing the shift did was stop me from
hitting 400 oh okay because you can't
you can't catch it if it's in the water
I was like ah
yeah that's funny so so so it was it was
a great experience so
I want to ask like
you know we had we both won MVP in 18
right and then how has it been I mean I
guess he kind of touched on it earlier
but
trying to return back to the MVP form
like from what I understood earlier is
I'm not really trying to do that I'm
just trying to be who I am today yeah is
that kind of is that kind of where where
I think you I think you chase it for a
while yep you know like obviously spend
your time chasing it yeah I've I've
struggled a little bit the last few
years just trying to to kind of find it
again there's obviously some
things that happen but that's kind of
part of sports
um you know going through that stuff but
I think you want to just try and be the
best version of yourself and like give
what you have that day you know
obviously we're all striving to be the
best version of ourselves and
um you know what we can do out on the
field and it's just like just finding a
way to do that all the time and you're
always constantly working and trying to
make adjustments to yeah to do that like
you know I still feel like I got a lot
in there a lot in the tank left
um
you know and I'm I know you do too like
we still got a long time to play
especially you yeah you gotta you got a
minute left but um
yeah man in in a way like
you kind of just have to embrace it like
you know there's obviously the
frustrations of it and
um you know the expectations coming with
have done that and then you know signing
deals like everything that comes along
with all that
um and you just want to be you just you
just want to be the best version of you
whatever that may be
um and you got to put the work in and
then when you put the work in
it is what it is kind of once the game
starts like you can't really control
that like you can control what you do
before and how hard you work in your
preparation but then once once it starts
it's like you just gotta play yeah and
then and and if we don't like if we
don't play as well right
um
Giannis I I don't I don't know if you
saw the video when Giannis talked about
failure and I want to hear your like
your Viewpoint like do you agree with uh
well Giannis when he when he said that
because yeah you know I think you can't
just
All or nothing you know I'm saying
there's steps yeah in order to get to
where you want to get to I mean I
definitely agree with it I know
I know it's kind of like a polarizing
quote at the time like people were
either all in on it or like they
couldn't have disagreed more you know
but
playing sports like you know like
there's only one team that wins the
championship everywhere so yeah
did every team fail that didn't win the
championship no like I don't I don't
think that's true at all um there's
definitely teams that do fail there's
definitely teams that have failure of a
season but just because you didn't win
it all or you had a team that was super
talented and just didn't win it all it's
not necessarily a failure because
like in sports sometimes you just lose
like you just lose like it doesn't go
your way too yeah well they get paid too
or like
there's there's some luck involved in
winning too especially especially in the
playoffs like yeah you know there's
there's a few plays at the side of game
and they either go your way they either
go your way or they don't right and I
think so many times people who cover
Sports who analyze sports fans that
watch sports
there always needs to be like in that
their mind like somebody to blame oh
yeah you know like you can't just you
can't just be like well they just lost
like yeah you know like it didn't go
their way and they lost it's always like
it has to be this guy's fault it's the
coach's fault it's this player's fault
like there always needs to be somebody
to blame and to throw it on just
appreciating that instead of being like
hey like that team made the plays they
needed to make to win this bounce didn't
go our way and it happened and that's
why when you win it's so special because
it's so hard to do and so many things
need to go right like you need guys to
be healthy at the right time you need
those few plays to go your way like you
need to be playing all the time
and so it's not necessarily a failure if
you don't win at all like obviously
everyone's goal is to win the
championship like nobody
nobody on the Bucks wanted to lose right
you know like nobody was going into that
game being like well if we win that's
cool if we lose that's cool too like
obviously they want to win but sometimes
when you lose you learn and yeah that's
it makes you appreciate the times where
you do come out on top and you do win so
I being that I've won two I've got been
able to win a couple World Series like
in those World Series is the common
thing was
we got hot yeah like we got hot at the
right time and if you get hot at the
right time I don't care what team it is
right they're gonna win yeah the bounces
are going their way yeah guys are
pitching good you're making all the
diving plays doing everything the right
way and you're getting all the two out
yeah two out second and third hit yeah
and you score two you know so yeah
that's we played the Braves in 21 and
they beat us man they had 80 something
wins coming into the postseason and
are you hot I remember us thinking
before we played him we're like man this
is gonna be it's gonna be a really tough
series everyone thought we were gonna
win and end up playing you guys in the
LCS like ah we'll see like that's gonna
be a really really tough series and they
ended up beating us and then they ended
up winning the whole thing they got red
hot the right time and
tuck it the whole way yeah so all right
bro so I want to open up to the chat
um
Joe
okay uh there's a question that says I
don't know I can't say that mookie if
you weren't a baseball player you'd be a
bowler what would you be Ellie
that's a good question I don't really
know honestly like I for for as long as
I can remember I always wanted to play
baseball like never had a
never had a plan B and I I don't know if
that's a good thing or a bad thing the
Christian yellow chicken but for the
most part like
that's kind of how it has to be I think
like in like we were talking about the
minor leagues earlier
I kind of found like playing with guys
in the minor leagues who had like a plan
b or another option
would kind of tend to want to take that
option instead of putting it all in
instead of grinding because like you
know how it is dude especially back then
was that's a grind like you're on a
13-hour bus ride you eat dinner when the
bus needs gas so that's like that could
be three in the morning at an Alabama
rest stop yeah you know and you're
eating whatever was Waffle House yeah
whatever's on the rotisserie that was
there all day that nobody else wanted
you're like well I guess that's my
dinner so if you don't really want it
then you kind of
tend to maybe gravitate towards that
other option and it was just like well
here we are like this is there's this is
the only option because you're competing
against guys that where that is really
the only option like they are all in so
if you can't match that all in then I
just feel like it's not going to go as
well for you yeah I mean in in due time
you'll you'll find out what you want to
do you know yeah I mean you really want
to do it yeah and post baseball like who
knows what that ends up being like you
know I'm not I know I'm not going to
play baseball forever so
um obviously you get into some stuff
afterwards but my mindset as a kid or in
the minor leagues was like I'm I'm going
all in on this and we'll see what
happens after all right so what about
who's your favorite artist listen to
um
I'm not really the clubhouse DJ I think
we got a bunch of guys in there that
that have a good mix it's usually for us
it's whoever's starting that day okay
that's normal yeah they kind of play the
stuff so
you know being in baseball you get to
listen to all kinds of stuff yeah
country to Latin music to rap like you
get a little bit you get a little bit of
everything in music yeah which is kind
of cool actually you get you learn a
bunch of a bunch of songs that maybe you
wouldn't listen to normally and then you
hear them like when you go out somewhere
and like oh okay you're like oh okay
cool yeah so I learned about Bad Bunny
back
yeah all right so if MLB players were a
slam dunk if MLB players were innocent
Slam Dunk Contest who do you choose
would win
I feel like a mere gear it would be a
pretty good but it'd be a very pretty
good choice I like the same thing he
used to kind of do that when he came in
yeah he did he came in from the bullpen
so I was like I'll take you
I feel like you could probably dunk but
no I wouldn't want to dance you wouldn't
want the dunk contest yeah I would I
wouldn't win I gotta stand there and
watch it a couple years ago because yeah
because coniston used me as a prop he
jumped up was that was that dope nervous
well there was another one like if he
Advanced there was one where it was kind
of gonna I was gonna have to flip him a
ball while he did a 360 and he was going
to catch it with his glove and dunk a
basketball at the same time that would
have been right so a lot of that was on
me to like flip it good and at the right
time the other one I kind of just had to
stand there yeah and
that one was pretty easy but I remember
I remember when he did it I couldn't I
didn't know if he made it or not because
I couldn't see like he threw out the
ball like my head kind of goes down he
dunked it and like the crowd reaction is
kind of the same whether you make it or
not it's like I remember him doing it
and I kind of like look up like did we
make it and then he was like he was all
fired up so I was like oh okay cool and
I was like oh all right sweet made it
and then
the next one would have been a little
bit of pressure if I had to flip them
because yeah that's that's like your
Dunk Contest
relies on my flipping ability right now
so I don't want to mess it up for you so
what about who uh who do we feel like is
the best player we've played with
oh
or against either one yeah
um I mean it's hard not to say the
obvious that Mike trouts though Tanya
yeah those guys are pretty it's hard not
to say those guys are pretty we just
played we just played Mike and and
shohei yeah
um which is crazy like what what shohei
is doing right now is
it's incredible it's honestly like to to
be able to to throw 102 miles an hour
and then hit 40 homers in the shows
I don't know how you could do that I
definitely couldn't do that and then
what Mike's done consistently for the
last 10 11 years is pretty impressive
too
um and just just sharing a few of those
guys is is pretty cool
um
you know I gotta play with Ichiro back
in the day which is which is pretty cool
to see him get 3 000 hits
um
I'd say I'd say I'd say a lot of
those guys right
they're they they weren't the FED
they're not the fastest they're not the
strongest they're not the most athletic
but they do it all together every day
you know what I'm saying like they don't
you they don't go hit the most
impressive VPS you know what I'm saying
Mike Trout isn't going throwing
everybody out right no but he throws
guys out and he hits 40 every year you
know what I'm saying hit the quietest 40
Hummers in the League last year no one
talked about it and then you like look
up and you had 40 homes yeah and he
missed like 40 years that's you know
what I'm saying so
um you know
it's not even just like
I feel like the people that I've I've
played with I've seen a lot of very
talented people but as far as just
putting it all together you know those
guys
you know the obvious guys are are the
best ones that I played with I think
yeah I mean you're kind of one of them
too dude but when you watch the when you
watch the
when you watch the star players like
when you it's kind of just different
like everybody plays the game but when
when you get like the Superstar level
players like the game just looks
different yeah they play it
um
I can't really describe what it is I
don't know if you agree like when when
they hit or when they're doing like the
game just looks a little bit different
like they're controlling yeah we're
gonna see what he does yeah what not
what our guy is doing like okay we got
to see what he does hopefully he doesn't
hit a home run hopefully he doesn't you
know hopefully he gets himself out yeah
and it's hard that's real though I think
everybody would say the same thing
especially or like the ball comes off
different or like you know like even out
like you said even outs are a little bit
different yeah yeah I know exactly what
you're saying it's like to a normal
person or like if it's kind of hard to
describe that but when you play like the
game kind of looks different to some
guys
so what about this uh would you ever
want to take a slide down the slide
after you hit a home run like run up
there after yeah call time out yeah and
just run up there to the third deck
I don't know the way baseball's going
you never know these days you know by
the time we're done playing maybe it's
like a full-on full-on skit before I let
you go bro
tell me about your charity you got a
charity yeah coming up soon event coming
soon tell me about it so yeah it's the
it's the first one
um we meant to do it a few years ago but
obviously with covet and everything that
kind of happened it wasn't really
possible but um it's just a charity to
raise money for uh you know facilities
redoing baseball fields in Milwaukee
um so kids have an opportunity to play
on on good fields and and renovate them
and
um you know maybe have some stuff go
towards like an indoor bubble to where
you know it gets cold here in the winter
and have an opportunity to have a place
where they can play inside and kind of
get better at what they do you know
being from you know there's places
California Arizona Florida like all
these baseball hotbeds you can play year
round in some places you just don't
really have that opportunity whether
it's facilities or
um you don't have a place to go so just
working on on giving kids the the
opportunity to uh you know play sports
year round here and
um raise some money so they have some
better facilities nice yeah bro thank
you uh thank you for coming on man
thanks for having me so one this has
been uh super dope uh one of thanks to
thank the fans for uh joining make sure
you follow bleacher report for more
content for more on base content we will
be doing this throughout the season so
uh shout out to Christian Yelich for
joining us and I will see you guys later
thanks for having me dude hope is a good
first one a lot of pressure being the
first ones it was amazing appreciate you
bro
[Music]